torture convention what's a torture
convention is that like comic-con but
for [ __ ] immigration give us your
tired your poor your huddled masses
yearning to breathe free
sometimes today we're gonna find out
what does it take to get into America
and I allowed to lie on this test it's
not a good idea both my parents are
immigrants but I have no idea what the
steps are I don't know if they had to
like submit headshots would be like an
audition reel hello my name is Jay I
like freedom but after use ik and that
like cowboy boots America I'm Hiroshi
mother Maura I teach law at the UCLA
School of Law is it easy to get into
America defendant who you are so we let
about a million people in the country
illegally every year I don't want people
pay for the war a lot of people should
be less so you can't just come because
you want to come if you want to I mean
it's a long process and it's longer for
some people another depends probably on
the country you're from your skill level
I hear a lot about the immigration
system is broken
well yeah it's broken that's the one
thing that people worry about how is it
drug how's it broken right today we're
gonna find out just how hard it would be
to actually immigrate and then become a
citizen in the United States of America
you have to you have to pass a test of
history at Civic it's often said that a
lot of Americans wouldn't be able to
pass it as a [ __ ] test we're gonna find
out today in Tennessee they mostly only
teach you Tennessee history and that is
super useless what do we call the first
ten amendments to the Constitution the
first ten in the cowboy the Bill of
Rights the Bill of Rights the Magna
Carta it's been a long time since I did
school who is the governor of your state
is a governor of our state card of him
who is he what they look like old white
what is the last day you can send in
federal income tax forms and again I
think I actually know this because I
always missed this date no April 20th is
4/20 that's not the answer that's not
the answer
what did susan b anthony news susan b
anthony designed the first u.s. flag she
was a boss ass [ __ ] indeed oh man you
passed yeah that's good news as far as
shit-ass goes the more complicated part
of this is even giving in the jews with
people that's a lot to take it unless
you've had a green card for five years
wait what
so we're gonna be putting ten or fifteen
years if they're waiting to get a green
card that's for the green card just for
the great this one explain what we're
talking about is coming to this country
as a so-called gamer you're not a
citizen this is about getting in and
being allowed to stay indefinitely being
a citizen is a whole other set of issues
that you have to jump through puts all
these waters in the air where are the
troops coming from
today we're gonna meet some people who
are citizens some people who aren't
citizens yet but people who come to
America to live a better life my family
is from Iran they came to the United
States right after the Iranian
Revolution my was executed my mom was
the next one that was supposed to be
executed she escaped with my other on
both on horseback going through the
mountains he's trying to find someplace
I go I moved to the US five years ago to
study college so I had to apply for a
student visa my hometown Tampico Mexico
was undergoing lots of darker tell
violence at the time I left both because
of safety reasons and also to give
myself more opportunities we're gonna
simulate how you go in the country
legally in a four different ways to get
into this country employ your relatives
are you get a job prospect we also
protect people fleeing persecution and
there's this longer I've written had a
few pretty typical stories a couple of
them are from Iran a couple of them are
from Mexico Zach and I are going to be
here with morale to represent either on
and then morale will help contextualize
the Iranian perspective she's here to
make sure we don't [ __ ] it all up it's
crazy to think it's easy to get in the
country I mean it's easy if you have a
PhD and even won a Nobel Prize Eugene is
a 23 year old woman
and your name is avi day and you're a
student at a university studying physics
and chemical engineering think of
routing me some are smarter than real me
recently spoken out against this long
I think I have a crush on Iranian regime
don't have a crush on fake me you've
received some threatening phone calls
accusing you of subversive politics that
you don't know who made the calls you
think it'd be a good idea to think about
leaving Iran and you think about the
United States people are calling and
threatening my beautiful holiday I don't
know you we've never met so now here's
here's your story now you're a college
grad and you work as a bank officer at a
private bank in Mexico City you often
travel internationally and recently met
and fell in love with a man from Peru
and he got his green card six years ago
the two of you want to marry my husband
you want to bring with you with six year
old daughter and a four year old son
from a previous marriage in Europe first
husband turned into a cat and you have a
mother who's attached to her
grandchildren and would be heartbroken
if they went with you to LA you're a 55
year old man I'm poetic lads you've been
working as a barber living and it's here
on some probe I'm afraid you've been
recently widowed and means I'm single
you have a sister and the sister
emigrated 15 years ago to Los Angeles
where she owns a hair salon so I need to
get my sister to become a citizen then
you could just marry this no no Morrell
that's not works okay you work as a
carpenter and a landscaper in Mexico the
whole construction industry isn't drying
up in your town you think your prospects
or your free children would be much
better in the United States I'm a family
man I want to set a good example one
thing I didn't tell
you dropped out of high school [ __ ]
should have done that but times three
was I was partying a lot back then
or you couldn't afford to be in school
realistically you just need to work
there's a lot of other reasons you might
drop out from high school party he likes
party and that's it everybody likes
party I'm just me I'm me
Mariano party man okay so you've got a
tough choice to make
wow this is a lot to unpackage do I have
any superpowers what do we know about so
I would say that she comes from a pretty
well-off family also that she's a highly
intelligent so I naturally abuse no wait
you have some funds you have an income
you don't have family here you don't
have a job you don't have a claim for
persecution and you don't win the
lottery you're out I'm going to go for a
work visa because they have the most
magical fingers and all of tada it's
possible your sister could sponsor you
but she's gonna have to show that you
are not taking a job away from the
American worker that's all I had to fill
out I'm gonna prove that you wouldn't
take anyone elses jobs yeah they have to
basically advertise the job
ejected for legitimate reasons and we
can hire you within that process and
take several your do we have scissors
here because I can show you how good I
am I think like a nice fade on the side
stop making us not want first of all I
have got some dependents and I love to
go to LA just like to visit first means
is a so-called non-immigrant visa that
means that you have to convince someone
let's say at the US Embassy that if you
come into the United States as a tourist
you will actually leave so no no I am I
for us oh okay so I was gonna say get
tourist fees that go get married
so the US government is gonna give you a
visa if they think you might overstay
love-love knows - no loss then rob the
bank
I might have well-founded persecution
right you're gonna have to show that
this amounts of some kind of pattern
we're really under some kind of threat
you don't think that his threatening
phone calls are credible enough you've
only gotten a few calls
Hiroshi you say a few as if this is a
normal thing you don't exactly want to
put yourself out there so you get more
threats right there are so many
countries in the world that you say one
thing and it's a life-and-death
situation and you're done much rather
have a student visa then put myself in
more danger to prove that I'm in danger
it's not you a cousin who's living but
without papers in Los Angeles and he
offers to do what
can to help you move to LA and is that a
quick quick application process there is
a temporary worker program by a
five-year visa and confirms practically
speaking of a year a year you might be
thinking I want to get a green card
problem is it's really hard to do that
if you don't have a college degree could
I finished high school now and apply to
a college that's an option and I need to
make money I don't need to pay money
yeah you have a family do I have any
friends with strong photoshop skills and
I could get a diploma that's a fake
diploma so you're relying on family
connection I think that's all I got your
sister could become a citizen if she
wasn't already and she can sponsor you
but the problem with that is then you
get into a line that's many years ago
well is that not the fastest line 15 or
20 years 15 to 20 years that's probably
on the country you're from that's a long
line some people it's a retirement
program god I need to be gonna be here
forever
everyone at the State Department puts
out this list of who we're letting in
today so if you're from a big country in
terms of population you gotta wait
longer than if you're from a smaller but
if you marry someone who is your citizen
then technically there's no line where
should we can't marry then what type of
addresses should I have a bridesmaid for
that's the important question here one
thing that does count your favorite is
that you can bring your children with
you what about I believe the problem is
you can bring your children but not your
parents
think about this it's gonna take like
ten years how old you know people come
and go and I don't want a winter wedding
just let me just mention a couple of
complications with every day scenario
one is that you've got to be able to
prove financial support for this period
because you won't be allowed to work and
then you have to find a job within your
field of study so it's not like you can
be a waitress for like to pay rent or
something you have nine days to find a
job within your field of study
I'm not dating you you do not have any
money and he doesn't you say I'm
currently on an h-1b work visa a visa
that the current administration has
promised to get rid of he's got a
permanent job the employer could sponsor
you this is complicated though my path
to citizenship would be through my
employer so I would need to stay with my
with my organization for a long time for
them to sponsor me through the whole
green card process this is the plight of
all of my international student friends
I have a couple of friends who are
international students with me and they
weren't able to find jobs so now they
have to go home unfortunately that was
not the case for me does this mean we're
getting married
hell no damn okay so I feel like my plan
now since I don't want to leave that boy
Lita I'm gonna get Eduardo to apply for
citizenship get married maybe we'll live
in Mexico City for a while
tend to
and then after she passes we can move to
LA I don't know I don't know what to do
I'm gonna build a boat this sounds very
biblical and I'm gonna sell the boat now
I got some money I'm building another
boat but family on that boat we're gonna
go up the coast we're in America why
can't it work has anyone ever tried the
double boat methods getting creative
here I'm gonna do something to save my
family
I got three kids depending on me there's
no path for me a lot of this has to do
with the mismatch between what our
economy seems to want and the people we
actually I do
millions of employers in this country
who think they need immigrant workers
who you have a Congress is not willing
to create lines to stand then if you
don't have a college degree harming our
jobs better I can build you know it's
boats boats boats today's a lot people
say why do they want to stand in line
was no longer standing but I also
immigrants to do a lot of the work that
keeps businesses in this country and
they create jobs for all kinds of people
including a lot of Americans what is
what is this paperwork but the form
you're looking at is for someone who
wants to get a green card I think you
gave me multiple by accident giving me
anxiety just to see them
had to fill out so many of these forms
before there's a separate form for
temporary workers and then this is to
become a sin 5 years later you know the
citizen maybe I should just go to Mexico
City it seems like there's a lot of
banks there I think kids would be
friends no fees could run you and
hundreds to a few thousands of dollars
lawyers fees might run you thousands of
dollars but they're complicated issues
in the case I don't think I have enough
money to fill out these forms and eat
but there's one of the complication I
want to mention and that is a travel ban
in effect oh yeah that thing the basic
idea is to suspend immigration from 4-7
now six different countries I mean the
one that's most affected is Iran
actually I mean about half the people
affected and there's also a separate
reduction number of refugees that are
allowed to come in so it's been defended
as a security measure but it's being
challenged by saying that it's a pretext
it's also challenged by saying hey this
is really targeting Muslims it's falling
from the campaign promise of a Muslim
I remember distinctively the day that my
mom texted me about the travel van I
couldn't she was like call me like I
could hear the tears in her voice it was
very much of her just talking about how
many families don't have a future
becoming your citizen was only available
to free white person's it's only in 1952
1950 to 1952 is the first time Congress
says we're gonna let you become a
citizen regardless of country or from
what we think it was monomeric I used to
be seen as really exotic there's a time
in the mid 1800s where the real concern
was Catholics because they own
allegiance to the Pope they couldn't
possibly be good American history
doesn't repeat itself but it often
rhymes I chose to go a more student
based rap you might and a lot of people
do leave themselves open to getting job
offers when they graduate that is gonna
allow you to get a green card but there
are a lot of pitfalls along the way a
lot of people don't make it through I
mean a lot of people don't ever find
that employer you don't know how long
it's going to take you don't know if
something's going wrong having
mom come visit you later that might be
tough because there's a suspicion maybe
she'll stay and you got to make some
choices about your family life it's like
I can ultimately make it to America but
it would come at great personal
sacrifice even though that's the
quickest path supposedly they've gotten
so much harder over the years she can
she can try to sponsor you but that's a
really long line it's really measured in
decades now and so like eights and I
suppose there are some people who think
that's the way the system ought to be
but no matter where you come out on that
I mean the fact is it's really hard to
get into this country how many people
would you say are kind of wanting to
come to America but there's just no path
no the answer has got to be in the
millions because you know we have 11
million people in this country who don't
have legal status and people sometimes
say why don't you stand in line well I'm
not sure there's much of a line for you
to stand in I'm gonna come here without
papers to just send money back to my
family until they finally well a lot of
people are doing that that's what I
would do and I totally understand why
you do that I'm ashamed at how much I
was unaware of so much of whether or not
you can get to America is out of your
control it's where were you born what
how much money were you born into did
you have the privilege and the
opportunity to get an education because
guess what you could also work really
hard and still not get it many times we
talk about immigrants with this blanket
terminology when in fact it's a very
nuanced highly personal diverse
perspective driven process that changes
from individual to individual and
generally it favors people who have
higher education
a little bit more money and so I think
that's the sad thing is that the most
unamerican thing is trying to block
people out who are doing the most
American thing working hard down their
life for anyone to have a perspective of
those people shouldn't be here
America first it's garbage people are
dying in other countries that's why they
want to come here they want to have
lives the fact that we're here just
speaks to what America can be and what
it should be and that we all are just a
human race you know
you